before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
Merry Christmas now
find out what's inside the Box
[Music]
happy holidays to all it's funny I've
actually been thinking about doing this
topic for quite a while when uh going
over things that I have yet to truly
dive in on in regards to Doctor Who and
uh then this particular Saturday which
is my normal video release date was
coming up and I'm like oh it's Christmas
Eve
oh that's perfect so yes
much like a present that might be under
your tree we're going to talk about
mystery boxes it's a little bit tortured
but
Go With It Just Go With It we're here
let's have fun
so I have talked in general offhandedly
in a number of videos none of which I'm
going to link because it's probably
happened more times than I could even
account for my general
distaste exhaustion might be a better
word with the mystery box format of the
overarching stories for Doctor Who uh
particularly modern era Doctor Who not
really an issue going back to Classic or
at least not a persistent one
so
there's a couple of things I need to go
over I need to actually Define what I
mean by mystery box and then I need to
explain why my issues with it exist but
also acknowledge that it has been done
better sometimes than others so let's uh
let's get through all this first of all
to find our terms what do I mean when I
say Mystery Box well the first thing
that's worth clarifying because I've had
people really misunderstand something
fundamental about my issues with the
mystery box which is that when I say I
am tired of the mystery box
that does not mean that I am tired of
every and all form of overarching
narrative for a given series
Doctor Who has been doing the mystery
box so consistently their do genuinely
seem to be fans out there that seem to
assume that when you say you don't like
a mystery box you don't like an
overarching story
a mystery box is a particular format of
overarching story something running in
the background between when the series
starts usually introduced if not in the
very first episode soon after
and then sort of continuing as something
that you get little reminders of being a
thing that exists but you don't really
find out what it is until the finale or
very close to the finale maybe in the
case of a two-part finale the first part
of uh the two-part finale so there's a
reason why I specifically go with
mystery box now that's a term that is
actually largely associated with JJ
Abrams he's very fond of mystery boxes
more in terms of when he talked about
the movies and marketing and in a way
the mystery box as Doctor Who does it is
a bit of a marketing play it's something
to keep the audience on the hook and
make them Wonder Don't You want to find
out what this is here's the main thing
that I want to distinguish about when I
say mystery box
a mystery box is distinct from an
overarching story with a mystery element
by virtue of they're not really being
any kind of plot movement on it other
than to remind you it exists until you
get an answer so to make a comparison
let's take a look at bad wolf from
series one of Doctor Who and the
overarching story of season three of
Buffy the Vampire Slayer yes issues with
Joss Whedon gone over all that just let
me use it as a narrative example okay
it's relatively well known so
this first series of modern era Doctor
Who Chris frackelston series very much
features a mystery box in the form of
bad wolf bad wolf is a phrase that
begins to appear across the series as
graffiti as a call sign for a helicopter
as an offhanded thing said by another
character as just something that keeps
recurring
but we don't know what it means it
effectively has no meaning whatsoever
and characters
at one point eventually note that it
seems to be a thing but also then
quickly move on from that idea and
that's not until towards the end of the
series anyways everywhere we go two
words following us how can they be
following us
nah just to go incidents like hitting a
word on the radio then hearing it all
day never mind basically it's just this
reminder here's the thing ooh ooh don't
you want to know what it is until we get
to
um well it's not even the episode Bad
Wolf really it's The Parting of the ways
we get a full answer for what that is
but that's what I mean when I say
mystery box
we basically know nothing about a thing
other than okay so it it exists okay
and we just get strung along until we
find out what it is and retroactively it
might have meaning I'm not arguing that
the actual bad wolf has a narrative
thing had no impact on earlier parts of
the story obviously it did by the nature
of how bad wolf works with Rose Tyler
she then sort of filters back in time
and implants it like that's obviously
plot relevant but I'm saying as you are
watching
as you are watching one episode to the
next it has no meaning Until the End
retroactive meaning does not count
because it's not until you reach the end
that you get any of that so any given
story in which bad will feature prior to
the very end find out what the heck it
even is you could have removed the bad
wolf reference nothing changes it
impacts absolutely nothing other than to
just remind you there's a thing that we
don't know what it is yet
compare that to
the mayor's plan in season three of
Buffy now that absolutely has mystery
elements to it the primary one being
that until towards the very end of the
season and it's longer than Buffy it's
more than twice as many episodes I think
well not twice but close to twice as
many episodes we don't know what the
mayor is ultimately trying to accomplish
we don't know exactly what it is his
plan is going to culminate in there is
absolutely a mystery to that
but regardless of what it is he's doing
he still impacts the plot moment to
moment episode to episode every time he
shows up it is moving something forward
it is impacting other characters that is
impacting their decisions it is taking
actions that directly result in certain
things happening we may not know exactly
what's going on until the end but the
structure of that season of Television
is not a mystery box it is an
overarching story that is continually
directly impacting the plot with a
mystery element to it which is that we
don't know what it is he's trying to
accomplish there's actually a fair
number of seasons of Buffy that do that
to some degree it's why it was an easy
example
but the key thing for me when I say
mystery box is
we have absolutely no idea what this is
and its presence doesn't matter until it
is explained at the very end
so how often does Doctor Who do this
almost every single time I already
mentioned series one bad wolf in series
2 we have Torchwood which is a little
bit of a softer mystery because it kind
of gets implanted early on by Queen
Victoria as to what Torchwood is going
to do investigate these strange
happenings and to fight them
I would call it Torchwood but the extent
to which it is uh affecting things and
exactly what it is up to and how it fits
into everything is not laid out
completely and it is something that
still fits the overall structure what
about torture representing the Torchwood
archive we get a reminder throughout it
until it actually impacts the plot at
the very end this is probably the most
debatable as far as mystery boxes go
because as I said with Queen Victoria
sort of setting up the Torchwood
Institute at an early episode in the
show we do kind of get a very early
indication of what this thing is even if
we don't really get to know until the
very end but I still do think that if
it's the overall format in terms of
intermittent reminders hey here's the
thing that's gonna be in the finale
series three we have vote Saxon hinted
at uh early on where we just have
mentions offhandedly of Mr Saxon
proves Mr Saxon right we have the
posters this is one of the more subtle
ones actually because other than the
early mention of Mr Saxon and like one
or two other instances it's not as uh
invasive or as uh persistently kind of
in your face as some other examples but
it does still fit the same structure we
don't know who Mr Saxon is until we get
to the two-part finale
series 4 effectively has three mystery
boxes that all get tied up one right off
the bat the reappearance of Rose how is
she here where'd she come from she's not
supposed to be able to be in this
universe so that's the first one we have
the a slightly subtler than that planets
keep disappearing after their breeding
planet was lost what do you mean lost
how'd you lose a planet that is an odd
thing and as it comes up by the second
or third time you're starting to go wait
a minute and then there's the bees
disappearing which is the most subtle
and probably wouldn't have carried it on
its own but that is another thing that
factors in terms of us ultimately
getting answers within the last three
episodes for those various things so
that's series four even this David
Tennant specials had their own Mystery
Box in the form of he will knock four
times that one is a little bit
interesting in that it has a deliberate
mislead as part of it especially once
the master gets introduced in the end of
time part one because you would assume
that that's the he it's referring to and
the actual reveal of who it is is one of
the more clever twists as far as these
ghosts but again the format it still
fits Series 5 gives us the cracks in
time and this is also another one where
people tend to argue with me a little
bit they'll go but it's not a mystery
box because they do impact the plot like
yes but also inconsistently the nature
of what the crack in time does varies
from story to story and a good chunk of
the times it appears in series five it
just shows up you just see it it does
nothing but you just see it that is the
epitome of a mystery box and even the
instances where it does a thing
exactly what it's doing is not 100
consistent because it becomes an opening
that you can pass through in the 11th
hour to then later be something that is
devouring things in the uh time of the
angels and so it's still kind of being
Twisted to fit a story that could have
been done without it being there already
or like it didn't have to be a recurring
thing it could have just been a one-off
thing within that episode again this is
and I'll come back tool this this is
kind of an instance where it is worked
into more stories as an actual impact
than is often the case but I'll sort of
talk about these stronger instances
versus the weaker instances a little bit
down the road Series 6 gives us the
Impossible Astronaut less the standard
Mystery Box format because it's so in
your face right off the bat as to what
it is and why it matters that it doesn't
need as many frequent reminders across
the series that a lot of these mystery
boxes do but it is still something
introduced very early on that will not
get resolution until we get to the end
Series 7 again ends up being a little
bit of an outlier it often is because it
is kind of split into two halves the
first half doesn't really have much of a
mystery box aspect to it the second half
though very much does that being the
impossible girl AKA Clara Oswald now
this is an interesting case where the uh
mystery box is actually a character but
I've talked about what I've uh discussed
Clara before that it's part of the
reason why she actually works the worst
for me in series 7 of any of the series
that she was around for because she is
not allowed to be a properly fleshed out
character because she has to maintain
that air of mystery because she's
functioning as a plot device at least as
much as she is functioning as a
character I would argue more so so it
was a neat little experiment to try and
give the mystery box more of a presence
very literally in this case but I still
don't really think it works
series 8 it's Missy it's just Missy
um we get introduced to her early on and
we don't know what her deal is we get a
couple reminders of her until we get a
reveal of who she is at the end series 9
the hybrid
oh the hybrid okay yep uh we'll come
back to this when I discuss the best and
the worst and how it can work and how it
can go very badly we'll come back to it
Moving On series 10 The Vault this one
is a little bit of an outlier as well
because the resolution of the mystery
box the answer to who is inside happens
kind of near the halfway point of the
series overall it doesn't hold on to it
until the very end which is also an
interesting variation and something I'll
come back to series 11 basically didn't
have one series 11 Jody Whitaker's first
series was built to largely be
self-contained stories now technically
the Timeless child did get introduced in
series 11.
what did you just say however
it doesn't get any follow-up mention
within that series and it's not going to
come up again until we get to Series 12.
so like at most I could give you would
be that it is a two series mystery box
as opposed to the standard resolved over
the course of one series I'm not even
sure I do that though
C12 it is the Timeless child it gets
reiterated picked up on again and sort
of moves the whole thing forward to
eventually give us the answer at the end
of series 12. series 13 AKA flux I don't
think really has one that's not super
surprising given that it is a shortened
condensed I'm gonna go with
semi-serialized story and as a result
like it's just not built in the way that
accommodates for a mystery box format
the way that normal Doctor Who is I.E
minimum 10 episodes at least a chunk of
those are self-contained so that if
you're going to remind folks about an
overarching story it's just going to be
sprinkled across these that's just not
the format of flux so it doesn't really
apply there there are plenty of mystery
aspects to flux
a lot of which don't get satisfying
answered but that's a completely
different issue so that is honestly the
one I think we can completely discard
out of this conversation but those are
the examples of the mystery boxes
what's the actual problem well for me
there's a couple problems the first is
predictability the format became
actually stale I would say by the end of
rtd's first run so series one through
four plus the specials I was kind of
done I I would really hoped that Moffett
would not recycle that format but he did
pretty much immediately arguably giving
one of the better examples of it again
I'll kind of come back to that but part
of my issue with the mystery box is less
about its inherent issues although it
does still have some for me and more
about the fact that it's just really
tired and really predictable
it has just become a case where this is
what Doctor Who does
this is just what you're gonna you're
gonna get some phrase that you're like I
don't know what that means but you hear
it repeatedly like okay
whatever that is it's it's gonna be
explained in the finale it'll matter I
still don't know what it is and a lot of
times you're not even really given a
reason why you should care
you're just sort of giving oh hey this
thing don't you want to know
I don't know are you gonna give me a
reason to want to know
that is part of the reason why I think
series five is one of the better
examples because it does well before the
finale get to showing you how the cracks
in time are damaging so while the
mystery remains where did they come from
how do we stop it the actual existence
of them being a problem gives me more
motivation to want those answers
whereas bad wolf Mr Saxon the hybrid the
Timeless child all of these things I'm
not given a reason to actually care
about the answer there's just a
presumption that here is a mystery don't
you want the answer
look I enjoy a good mystery and maybe
part of the problem for me is I'm not
big on speculation I'm not a big
theorist I'm not really big about
predicting what's going to come next I'm
not the kind of
um fan or YouTuber who is gonna pick
apart for Easter eggs and go oh I think
I have a theory of how it's all going to
come together like my brain just doesn't
work that way it it just doesn't flatly
I I I could barely if I go out of my way
force myself to try and think like that
it's really not it's really just not how
it works for me and maybe for people who
are more inclined to do those kinds of
things or engage with Phantom in those
ways maybe they never want this to go
away I mean you know what this is a good
point for me to point out that's fine
just because I am tired and frustrated
with these things does not mean you have
to be this is not about saying why you
shouldn't like something this is about
me explaining why I
tend to not like something so
there is not always the work put in as
to why I should care about these answers
now sometimes depending on how good the
answer is maybe by the time we get to
the end I will care even if I didn't
during the journey but that is still
diminishing that Journey as you drop
these reminders and maybe by the time we
get to the end it'll have meaning and be
delivered and culminate in something
that makes me go oh
okay which arguably something like bad
wolf or even Mr Saxon kind of did but
until we get to that end point
a reminder I'm just like yeah no I know
I know I've picked up the pattern I know
that's the thing you're stringing out
I am no more or less interested than the
last time you brought it up because you
haven't given me a reason to be
that's that's just kind of where I land
a lot of the time with these things they
just
the honestly more often than not they
feel like a substitution and the uh sort
of vague hint of having a series Arc
when really the plot
doesn't Arc
you're just you're just telling us in
advance something that will matter at
the end but that's not an arc that's not
a Continuing Story that's not a shifting
of the overall uh situation for
characters or the world as a whole from
episode to episode because of this thing
it's just going through a bunch of
Adventures most of which would be
completely unchanged if you remove the
reference that you just happen to drop a
reference in
okay
and that's the that's the thing for me I
don't really care most of the time and
so even if it ends up being a good
answer during the trip I still don't
care
the destination might be good but I'm
bored until then well with that specific
aspect anyway if it's good episodes that
no I won't be bored I just won't be
engaged in that particular aspect
but as I said I do feel some of these
were done better than others and if I'm
going to be completely blunt about it
I think as a rule a general rule
Moffett did them better than uh Russell
T Davis did
so RTD introduced The Format and I again
keep in mind this is based off his
initial run of series one through four
and then the tennis specials who knows
what he'll do when he comes back and we
get this new specials with ten and then
we get shooty got to a could be a whole
new ball game could be a revisit the old
things we don't know
but looking at his original run
Russell's felt much more formulaic and
really did not feel like they were
playing with that formula just reusing
it
series to series year to year now
moffets I think are some of the stronger
instances of it I would say the one that
Davey's dropped that got me the most
invested at least in really wanting to
know the answer to the question was
showing us Rose at the start of series
four I was like yeah I want to know and
that gave us some reminders and I think
that's arguably one of his stronger
mystery boxes as a result of that but
it's because of pre-existing interest in
rows the actual execution of the mystery
box within series 4 is actually not
improved in any way it's just able to
bank on something I already cared about
to get me more invested than I am in
something that I literally have no idea
what that means but pretty much the
other ones just fall under the category
of this doesn't have meaning until we
get to the end the idea in series 4 of
Rose coming back that has meaning and
brings up questions so I said arguably I
think I am going to make the argument I
think that's his strongest
um Mystery Box to show us Rose somebody
that if you've been watching the show
you have an immediate investment in you
should already care and you're going to
want to know how that's happening
and
that just gives you more investment than
you're going to have in huh the term bad
wolf keeps showing up
huh the term Torchwood keeps getting
said
oh and yes I am aware of the fact that
torch would actually initially got
dropped in series one I'm not counting
that as the start of the um
of the mystery box for narrative
purposes all the remains of which famous
old Earth Institute the touchdown
just occurred to me pendants might point
that out and if anybody does it proves
that you commented before finishing the
video uh anyways but you know Harold
Saxon okay
that I don't have an investment in that
until I know what it is I already know
who Rose is and I know she shouldn't be
there so I'm invested but again
structurally it matches pretty much all
the others with Moffett I would say that
the cracks in time are definitely one of
the strongest implementations because as
I alluded to earlier their presence
actually impacts the stories they're in
not in a way that it would be impossible
to tell those stories without having
them there you could replace them with a
one-off uh equivalent you know within
that story itself the doctor can come up
with some other technobabble reason why
there's this energy sucking force in uh
the time of the Angels or why there's a
portal to uh Emilio young Amelia's room
in uh in the 11th hour or whatever you
could come up with other reasons instead
of the plot function the same but it
does give you a steady sense that this
is causing something to go so weird
and it ramps it up as we see it's
potentially damaging impact in time of
the angels and then later on we see it
do true damage to a character that we
care about when Rory gets lost to it and
we see that impact on Amy so while it is
still in many ways still fitting the
structure of a mystery box
it's not just giving us random reminders
it is doing that a little bit we have
those in things like victory of the
Daleks beasts below we just see it ooh
there it is
those are your standard Mystery Box
appearances but it also has appearances
where it matters and that's much
stronger rooting of the mystery box item
into the stories than usually happens or
really had ever happened with uh Russell
T Davis's era now
one of the other ones that Moffett did
that I quite rather enjoyed was series
10 because as I mentioned it's the Vault
the vault is introduced early on what's
in the vault that gets answered way
earlier in the series
which is another neat little Spin and a
neat little twist on that because once
that's answered
now you're like well
okay
what's gonna happen in the finale now
because that's another one of the issues
that I tend to have with the mystery box
is it makes it very clear one of the
things I already know to expect in the
finale it's gonna be the answer to
whatever the heck the mystery box is
that's going to be part of the finale
now I don't necessarily know what that's
going to be because if I already knew
what it was it wouldn't be a mystery but
it already at least sets me up to go
okay whatever else goes on this thing
will be part of it
but when you answer the mystery box
question around the halfway mark of a
series
what happens to the finale now
well now
that could be anything
and I love that feeling I love that
feeling of oh my gosh Anything could
happen now and I had that in series 10
and it's one more reason to add to the
pile on top of kapali being amazing and
Bill being great and Nardo being good
with both of them and Missy and some
fantastic episodes and like it's my
favorite series it just is it's my
favorite series of modern era Doctor Who
and this is just one more reason it's
not a massive uh uh you know shift of
the mystery box and actually I would
even argue myself that up until the fact
that it gets resolved way earlier than
you expect it to it is just a standard
mystery box like there's nothing
particularly interesting about the
specifics of How It's deployed it's just
the fact that it's resolved a lot sooner
than you think
and how that frees up the story to do
well anything but while I do feel
Moffitt did some of the better instances
of the mystery box he also did uh some
real egregious ones although I will say
at least these happened in the spirit of
trying to do something different which I
can't at least appreciate the attempt
even if it didn't work because you've
got things like the impossible girl I
mentioned already taking the mystery box
the MacGuffin
and making it a character making it a
person that's
on paper an interesting idea an
interesting spin to it different way to
do it didn't work
didn't work because in the interest of
maintaining her as a mystery she barely
functioned as a character if Jenna
Coleman was not as Charming a performer
as she is it wouldn't have worked at all
from a writing perspective I get why he
tried
it didn't really work but again it's an
experiment in a 20 thankfully seemed to
learn from because he didn't try and
repeat it but then we've got his
absolute fall down of a mystery box
which is
the hybrid you know what the basic
structure of a mystery box format should
necessitate answering the mystery
clearly
the fact that I still to this day see
people floating their ideas of what the
hybrid actually is and even getting into
fights in my comments section shows how
unresolved and unsatisfactorily answered
that entire mystery even was what is the
hybrid
I have my idea of what it's supposed to
be but I've seen like three other things
and whether or not any of us are right
there should not be this many open
interpretations to it because it was
driving the plot
it was driving the actions of almost
everybody involved
it would like it would be nice to know
why
and what
or any of it and I think what Moffat
might have been
trying
to do is to construct a mystery where
the answer didn't actually matter
because the fear of the mystery or
people's beliefs about the mystery
whether they were accurate or not we're
still driving their actions
I think that's what he was trying for
but that doesn't work for a number of
reasons one of which being
at this point nine series into the show
the audience is expecting you to answer
this and while I'm not inherently
against the idea of the answer being it
doesn't actually matter in fact many
things I like do flatly do that but
you have to be able to do it within a
setting and a format and a story where
the audience is going to be willing to
accept that and given what audiences
have been trained to do all eight series
prior to that uh no that was probably
not going to go over particularly well
and that's in addition to the fact that
there are still questions that needed to
be answered even if what the hybrid is
in specific never absolutely
definitively was like why were the time
Lords so concerned about the hybrid why
did they think the doctor knew anything
about the hybrid why do other characters
seem to know and reference about it so
like the part of it that I like I kind
of get is the idea that the uh time
Lords are acting in fear of this thing
and it doesn't really matter what the
hybrid actually is if they're afraid of
it then that's enough I get that but
there's still just a bunch of basic
logistical nuts and bolts that just
aren't
and then there's the Timeless child
which honestly I don't want to spend any
more time ranting about then
I have elsewhere or will have to do
again when I eventually get to covering
that in a take two Doctor Who
review which yes I I will get to I um
just overall
it is
one of the weaker examples because it's
just an idea and a phrase planted given
importance and not only does it not get
cleanly answered until the last episode
that answer
has very little direct impact uh on the
story
I think the only thing that you could
say it actually Alters is in theory
finding this out is what motivated the
master to kill Gallifrey except you
could have motivated the master with
literally anything to kill Gallifrey it
didn't have to be that and its impact on
the doctor was virtually nil its impact
on the actual immediate story was
virtually nil because all the
information was delivered as something
like this is a past tense information
this isn't even a current thing we're
dealing with and it's delivered in this
Exposition machine that is completely
separating the doctor from the rest of
the ongoing plot it's just badly
designed Moving on but again I do just
kind of want to stress there are well
executed mystery boxes and the Mystery
Box format is not an inherently bad
thing
there are more than a few that I
genuinely think are well done I've
highlighted them and there's others that
while they bored me a little bit during
their initial uh airing because I'm like
okay you keep bringing up this thing and
I don't know what it is on a re-watch
it's not as much of an issue
but overall I come back to what I said
was my initial main overriding problem
it's too often
it's the fact that I can really only
name two series out of 13 that didn't do
it those being series 11 and flux two
and a half if you want to make that
argument for the first half of series
seven
but other than that
every series
has done this it's really predictable
I'm really tired of it one of my
favorite things about Doctor Who is how
open it can be it can do anything it can
go anywhere anywhere in time and space
it can tackle almost any story face
almost any foe take on almost any tone
I love that it's part of what made me
fall in love with it in the first place
because that is Pure Imagination the
power to do anything
and yet we keep coming back to the
structure over and over and over again
I'm not uh gonna complain a ton about it
going
uh specials with David Tennant because I
kind of expect the mystery boxes why did
the doctor regenerate into that form
that they've already been before
especially when they didn't appear to
intend to do that
that has already set up that as a
question and if it is primarily driving
the character's actions right from the
beginning I'd actually argue that's not
a mystery box anyways that's a plot
driver there's a difference
but if when we get to shudigatwa's first
series
and it gets introduced as a mystery box
format for the overarching thing
I'm probably going to be really annoyed
I'm not saying we can never do it again
but you know
how could I miss you when you won't go
away
and like for more than a series like
give me a stretch of time
without this
give me like three or four series that
don't do this and then bring it back and
I and it could almost be a nostalgic
like oh they're doing that again
because otherwise I just watch and I'm
like what's gonna turn out to be the
mystery box What's the phrase
like right from episode one I'll be
listening all right what is it what's
the phrase that they're gonna keep
saying over and over again that I can
watch for
I don't want to sit there a doctor who
with a checklist
that's that's not how I want to approach
the show it should be grander Freer less
predictable
but those are my overall thoughts and my
issues and my gripes and my rantings
about the mystery box and its place in
Doctor Who
what do you think about this do you
think I gave a fair and accurate
breakdown to the structure as a whole
how it's been used in Doctor Who up to
this point what are your thoughts about
it do you like it do you like some more
than others what are your favorite
instances what ones do you think didn't
work whatever any of your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it
patreon's what pays the bills are around
here there's also a link down in the
description any amount that you can
assist with is really really helpful
it's what allows me to do this as my job
and keep making content at this pace and
at this quality for all of you folks to
enjoy but even if you're not able to do
that like shares And subscribe those
help me out a great deal as well
but what I really want you to remember
especially during the holidays
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
Merry Christmas
[Music]
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula
Tarak the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjarnasen Melinda
Walters imudelki the oatha Boyd catoria
toy lowly Becky Sparks for nabilox the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what you doing there
[Music]